[Música]
en visual política hemos criticado a
donald trump más que en ningún otro
canal de youtube sin embargo hay algo en
lo que sí tiene razón
edward beer si quieres ser un ciudadano
de méxico tú y vamos a asumir que eres
una persona perfecta no te dejarían ser
ciudadana mexicana es uno de los lugares
más difíciles para conseguir la
ciudadanía en este caso donald trump
dice la verdad méxico tiene una ley de
inmigración muchísimo más restrictiva
que la de eeuu para que os hagáis una
idea sólo en el año 2015
el gobierno mexicano deportó a más de
100.000 inmigrantes ilegales mientras
que eeuu 300.000 y si se lo que estáis
pensando que eeuu todavía de porta más
gente pero ojo pensad que méxico tiene
tres veces menos población y reciben
muchos menos inmigrantes que la primera
potencia del mundo
[Música]
si queremos esto en cuenta podemos decir
que los mexicanos reportan a
prácticamente todo aquel que entra en el
país a través de las fronteras con
guatemala y con belice o por lo menos a
todos aquellos que deciden quedarse en
el país en lugar de continuar su viaje
hacia los eeuu
de hecho os acordáis que hace unas
semanas sacábamos un vídeo hablando
sobre la inmigración en japón si
recordáis os decíamos y en el país del
sol naciente tienen solamente un 2% de
población extranjera y que eso es muy
bajo si lo comparamos con el resto de
países del mundo desarrollado verdad
pues bien la población inmigrante en
méxico no llega ni siquiera al 1% y para
que os hagáis una idea mientras el
presidente de méxico don enrique peña
nieto le espetaba esto a donald trump
los mexicanos en eeuu son gente honesta
y trabajadora son personas de bien que
respetan a la familia que respetan la
vida en comunidad y que respetan la ley
como tal los mexicanos merecen el
respeto de todos el 48% de la opinión
pública mexicana afirmaba tener una
opinión mala o muy mala sobre los
inmigrantes centroamericanos es más por
esas mismas fechas el diario mexicano la
mañana publicaba este artículo
y al muro fronterizo pero en el sur de
méxico el problema que vive en méxico y
eeuu se puede resolver y esto es con la
construcción del muro fronterizo
propuesto por donald trump pero en el
sur para evitar el cruce ilegal de
centroamericanos que como os quedáis hoy
vamos a ver a fondo la ley de
inmigración mexicana
porque méxico deportar a los
centroamericanos lo primero que tenemos
que entender cuando hablamos de
inmigración hacia mexico es su situación
geográfica imaginad que vivís en
nicaragua y queréis emigrar a los
estados unidos pero que no tenéis ni
dinero ni recursos para comprarnos un
billete de avión pues bien el único modo
para llegar al país de las oportunidades
por vía terrestre es cruzando méxico por
carretera y como os podéis imaginar el
mayor flujo de inmigración del mundo es
el que va desde latinoamérica hasta los
eeuu
solo en el año 2015 hicieron este viaje
más de 22 millones de personas y se
trata de una ruta peligrosísima por
carreteras en un estado pésimo y en
zonas ultra violentas no olvidéis que
estados mexicanos como chiapas guerrero
o sinaloa son los auténticos epicentros
del narcotráfico porque surgen todos los
abusos posibles extorsiones secuestros
tráfico de personas tráfico de
estupefacientes trata de personas con
fines de explotación laboral y sexual
para que os hagáis una idea muchas de
esas personas que llegan al sur de
méxico continúan su viaje hacia los eeuu
subidos en el techo de un tren de
mercancías a este tren se le conoce con
el sobrenombre de la bestia o el tren de
la muerte y ya os podéis imaginar de
dónde viene el nombre de familia que en
el fenómeno del migrante que hace que en
méxico esta situación fue la excusa
perfecta para que en los años 70 el
gobierno de mexico sacara su llamada ley
general de población una ley que entre
otras muchas cosas servía para evitar el
hacia los inmigrantes y cosas como la
trata de blancas el problema que lo que
en un principio podría parecer una
motivación noble se convirtió en un
auténtico infierno para los extranjeros
y os preguntaréis qué es lo que hacía
que esta ley fuera tan dura para los
inmigrantes para que os hagáis una idea
esta ley permitía al gobierno expulsar a
los extranjeros por razones tan
peregrinas como ésta
la secretaria de gobernacion podrá negar
a los extranjeros la entrada al país o
el cambio de calidad o característica
migratoria cuando lo exija el equilibrio
demográfico nacional
en otras palabras méxico solo está
dispuesto a recibir a extranjeros que
vengan de países ricos y hacer posible
que tengan la piel blanca el resultado
siete de cada diez inmigrantes son
estadounidenses y prácticamente el resto
vienen de españa es más hay dos veces
más españoles que a guatemaltecos esto
no sería ninguna sorpresa si no fuera
porque guatemala hace frontera con
méxico y españa está a miles de
kilómetros y con una cena de forma
pero no sólo eso es que además méxico
tiene prácticamente el mismo número de
alemanes que de peruanos en otras
palabras que si vienes desde europa o
desde eeuu no vas a tener ningún
problema en conseguir el visado porque
al parecer estás contribuyendo a
favorecer el equilibrio demográfico
ahora bien si estáis viendo este vídeo
desde perú y queréis emigrar al país de
chumel torres
lo siento pero os vais a tener que
buscar otro país en el que no se os
considere una amenaza demográfica
[Música]
pero no sólo eso es que con esta ley ser
inmigrante ilegal en mexico se
consideraba un delito federal eso
significa que en cualquier momento y en
cualquier lugar la policía mexicana
podía pararte por la calle y pedirte los
papeles y si no los tenías no sólo te
portaban a tu propio país sino que
además te obligaban a pagar una multa
que equivalía a dos veces el salario
medio mexicano todo esto podría pasar
inadvertido en la comunidad
internacional a fin de cuentas cada país
es libre de fijar las leyes de
inmigración que quiera pero en el año
2010 pasó algo que destaparía las
vergüenzas de toda una nación
la gobernadora de arizona jan brewer ha
firmado la ley de inmigración del estado
considerada una de las más duras de la
nación por irónico que resulte la ley de
inmigración de arizona pensada para
frenar el tráfico de personas que venían
desde mexico era prácticamente un calco
de la ley mexicana ahora bien a pequeña
escala porque por ejemplo aunque este
estado considere que la inmigración
ilegal es también un delito como no es
el gobierno de washington solamente lo
puede perseguir dentro de los límites de
lo que es arizona dicho de otra manera
no es un delito federal de esos que
persigue el fbi sin embargo esta ley
acapara la atención de todos los medios
de comunicación a lo largo y ancho del
mundo y el que por aquel entonces era el
presidente de mexico felipe calderon no
se quedó atrás toda regulación que se
centre en criminalizar el fenómeno
migratorio un fenómeno social un
fenómeno económico y criminalizarla de
esta manera abre la puerta a la
intolerancia al odio a la discriminación
al abuso en la aplicación de la ley con
un par de coj
sí señor a partir de ese momento en
algunos diccionarios aparece la foto de
felipe calderón junto a la definición de
la palabra hipocresía lógicamente la
reacción internacional no se hizo
esperar y por eso en menos de un año el
gobierno mexicano se vio obligado a
cambiar su ley general de población en
la que por fin sedes criminalizaba la
entrada ilegal en el país
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
no hemos terminado efectivamente méxico
cambió su ley de inmigración pero no del
todo recordáis que os decía que la
policía mexicana podía pedirle los
papeles a cualquier persona que pensara
que es un inmigrante ilegal pues es tal
cual por ejemplo en eeuu las autoridades
necesitan tener como mínimo la sospecha
de que han realizado un delito para
poderte pedir los papeles es decir que
no es tan fácil eso de pararte por la
calle y meterte en un furgón policial
sin embargo en mexico es totalmente
normal por ley las autoridades no
necesitan tener ninguna sospecha para
pedirte los papeles y si eso le sumás el
poco control que hay en este país sobre
su propia policía te encuentras con
cosas como esta
[Música]
para escapar de la deportación algunos
emigrantes pagan mordidas de entre 30 y
300 dólares a los policías pero esperad
un momento porque alguno pensará que el
caso de méxico es un caso aislado en el
mundo verdad normalmente cuando hablamos
de inmigración siempre nos referimos a
gente que viaja de países relativamente
pobres a esos lugares que son los más
ricos del planeta eeuu canadá o europa
verdad
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que solo en el año
2015 hubo más de 80 millones de personas
que emigraron de países pobres a países
que eran un poquito más ricos pero que
todavía seguían estando en vías de
desarrollo por ejemplo cada año hay
cientos de miles de personas que viajan
desde bangladesh hasta la india y no
penséis que le reciben con los brazos
abiertos precisamente y si no mirad lo
que decía el que ahora es presidente de
la india- narendra modi durante su
campaña electoral
lo podéis poner por escrito a partir del
16 de mayo los bangladesíes que viven
aquí pueden ir haciendo las maletas todo
esto contrasta con esa política
aperturista que tienen en otros países
como canadá o nueva zelanda que
curiosamente son dos de los lugares más
ricos del mundo
pero vosotros qué pensáis queréis que
eeuu o europa deberían seguir el modelo
de la india o de méxico o tal vez
deberíamos apostar por el modelo
canadiense en este vídeo os explicamos
por qué en canadá apuestan por la
cultura de recibir a la gente con los
brazos abiertos y por supuesto no
olvidéis que subimos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribimos al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado el
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]